you feel me baby ain't no one timeline
baby
you knew it I'm that cinnamon lemon
daddy I'm stayin seasoning you know I'm
stayin seasonal so welcome very
[Music]
stepmother oh whoa what was that - that
was an aunt with an axe oh oh oh when
they be scary dude if ants they had a
bunch of ants with like a little bitty
axes you know and they were just like he
want crumbs um
it's Halloween is the time yeah what's
that oh that's just a cauldron that's a
cauldron bruh and we had a guide our
school named caldron Patterson young
urban felon beautiful guy did a lot of
art not art but he painted like houses
and stuff like that he ended up getting
into house painting happy Halloween
[Music]
somebody getting slapped notice that you
can hear it's like a cool beat but then
somebody gets slapped every couple
seconds right there and they beaten that
person Oh Oh [ __ ] go that's kind of oh
man this slap a damn jawbreaker out of
your mouth right there that thing that's
um the werewolf dance by Martin land huh
and that is and we've all heard that
sound that beat that's um that's that
sounds scary but also a little bit of
domestic dispute kind of tickled in
there with the slappy oh let's stay
haunty today
[Music]
that sounds a little like Dexter like
Dexter is going to do some Halloween and
you know maybe listen little Dexter e
right there a little trick or trauma
what Dexter can you imagine if Dexter
showed up at your door
dude I would it wouldn't be good what
are you gonna give him dude you're gonna
have to give him your soul because
that's what he's gonna get
dude Dexter was such a good show how
good was Dexter and then you got some
other show you know like Larry and Abba
Schoeller some [ __ ] what else man lo
let's get into this a little thing
[Music]
that's kind of boring here's one let's
do this one
[Music]
that's not like somebody about to take
they tits out at like a real nice
Wendy's or something real upscale
Wendy's and that means just any Wendy's
that has a you know two doors on it
because everybody knows I've been in a
Windies out here in Los Angeles over
there Santa Monica and one of the doors
is missing you know one of those
in-and-out apparatus doors it is missing
off that there Wendy's and if Dave
Thomas were alive he would [ __ ] in his
apron because that's no way to go
through it happy Halloween that was a
little bit of intro music and just you
know getting people keyed up and
everything and and that's that and and
this is it this is it we got the studio
decked if you get to check this out
Nicholas premature Nick and if I don't
know if there's anything more you know
the coffin you know that's when the
coffins open you know the thoroughfare
is there and people can you know spirits
can come and go as they will and a
premature baby and that's what producer
Nick you know got here early he came
into the world a little bit early and
he's doing well early bird gets the worm
I mean the guy's doing really really
well and uh he's out of Wisconsin he's a
Wisconsin man and if you get near ups
and I'm gonna smelled a bit of milk on
him or something you know just something
you know you could definitely I mean
he'll wake up out of a dead sleep
cheering for Aaron Rodgers so he is from
Wisconsin happy Halloween to you hope
you hope this week have everything you
want in it some trickery some ghost dude
when I was young a ghost was like one of
the top costumes some do would be a
ghost I remember one guy that's got a
little Carlton and he didn't have I
don't know he didn't he couldn't walk
that good or he didn't want to honestly
bro he was lazy so he didn't you know
we'd all be walking somewhere and he
would kind of just kind of give up and
just stand you know he prefer to stand
or lay down or sometimes my friends
chef's this big guy he would carry him
and um and I remember talking about
hmm you remember man but I'm having a
little snicker boy you know that dude
have already had two so uh happy
Halloween to you they got the ghosts are
gonna be out they got uh and they got a
lot of different ghosts now oh that's
what I was saying when I was young they
had rare you know limited costumes very
limited and uh Carlton one time I
remember this dude was a transmission
that's what he was and he put some type
of metal or something on him and poured
a motor oil all over himself and we were
like dude what the [ __ ] man but but he
was beautiful beautiful kid had real
beautiful cheeks on him you know
sometimes on a child it's almost like
the Lord just [ __ ] Botox them with uh
you know just put like a just uh some
warming just a little bit of lava or
something in their cheeks and Carlton
had that he had beautiful ass cheeks too
and I wish he wouldn't have been so lazy
because more people would have seen his
cheeks but when you're not lazy you
don't run across as many people as you
should because you're not out making the
rounds of the world oh yeah boom know
what sign I would make if I'm dying I'm
dying dude I'm not making like a I don't
know my last thing I don't know what I
would do oh yeah some chicks would be
like that probably do some of these
thoughts out here
you know some of these saw Franken
thoughts out here they'd be like
yeah I hope we get a heaven yeah you
know would your last sound be he think
if you had a last sound that what would
it be if you had a really because it's
your last the last noise you're gonna
make in the world the last thing that's
gonna reverb out of you what would yours
be you think girl that's dumb that's
Badwan um oh that's a tough one that's
not that tough you got to have a tougher
one than that nah man that might be good
but if people if you do that you're
probably not gonna die if you have that
much energy to do that sound so it'd
have to be a soft maybe like a little
whistle or something like oh maybe a dog
runs over that's kind of beautiful at
the end you laid air and you drip you
know and then the dog runs over I
remember in college I got fired from
radio station for blowing a dog whistle
you know one of those dog whistles that
only dogs can hear allegedly I mean who
knows if they [ __ ] can but but uh I
got fired for blowing one of those on
the radio station all the time because
people would complain you know like I
can't listen to food fighters
you know because my damn Labrador hates
your uh your audio network you know oh I
can't even listen to this day you know
I'm trying to call in and get y'all to
play some juvenile you know I'm trying
to play back that ass up we out here and
my god cousin's funeral and we trying to
play back that ass up and uh and they
got it you know and they got six stray
dogs showing up over here on the dance
floor
so I don't know man y'all need to
tighten up over there and uh and that's
what it is
hadar what did I do this weekend this
past weekend man thank you guys for
being here today I do want to tell you
some dates just are coming up very
excited Lafayette Louisiana
December 26th at the Hyman Performing
Arts Center and a portion of the
proceeds to go to Dustin Poirier 'he's
good fight foundation very excited to
see that do Dustin called out a you know
Nate Diaz on it was hilarious he's in
the hospital bed because they took part
of his hip or something they put him a
dam I mean I think they're gonna replace
his hip with a damn chainsaw brother
dude's gonna be cutting people's heads
off he's gonna have them you know and
they know probably get a job doing
reforestation or timber so who knows I
mean that dude could be you know he
could be fighting by a day and he could
be fighting that night and doing uh and
building you know and doing working in a
lumberyard working it over there Dewalt
or something during the daytime but uh
and he was talking [ __ ] to um that man
Nick Diaz [ __ ] was hilarious unless it
was hilarious did he go read their
conversation back and forth it's pretty
funny but it was also kind of respectful
too it's pretty cool yeah this is it
this is a great time to get out there do
a costume you know when I was yelling it
and have as many costumes a ghost was a
popular deal especially in our
neighborhood you had to get a spare
sheet and I'm saying I remember having
that I remember I asked him for a sheet
for my birthday just to save that
bastard so I could ghost out you know
and some people you know a lot of kids
kids you know if you had a sheet a lot
of times you didn't really you know some
people called it more of a bastard
drapery because you didn't usually have
a daddy or something if he was just out
there in a sheet I mean one kid put a
would put a sheet on and put like a
little rope around his neck kind of and
he [ __ ] forgot to cut the holes into
it hell yeah dude ran outside and got
attacked by a bunch of [ __ ] stray
dogs so you got a I mean Halloween you
got to think you know you have to I mean
cut some face holes and stuff
but I remember getting into mass
remember you would put the title on it'd
be so hard to breathe you be like
trapped in there and that tight-ass
thing pressing into the back you had
that little and if you have one of them
cheap when the bra especially from the
if you got with something from like the
pharmacy or whatever your dad got you
that little outfit I remember my dad one
time got me and my brother he
accidentally got us both Raggedy Ann
instead of Andy so we were both out
there like it just a couple of straight
up sugar [ __ ] my looking for candy
going door-to-door hey little lady
people saying like oh my god I'm going
on the Handy but I'm just I got the
wrong you know uh
pseudo I got my sister's dress on that
was a shittiest man being locked in that
damn little [ __ ] face [ __ ] prison
that can't do that little plastic math
that [ __ ] cuts into your head you try
to stick your tongue out the little
breathing hole in there people dying
dude they yeah you put that thing that
mask on you something you could even
breathe sometimes you some people die
some guy you you know he put it on he
died like damn bro where's Leonard you
know and he's at the funeral and they
got on a death certificate Raggedy Andy
on their Frankenstein I don't even
[ __ ] look for his real identity just
wild man different time you know
different time
you know I remember one time when I was
at Halloween uh my dad had gotten you
know could my father was a senior
citizen hold on him I have a snicker
real quick cuz I deserve it mmm God my
god you could
snicker boy it's just like somebody just
threw a big old fine piece of ass in
your mouth you feel me mm-hmm
no god I love that little snicker boy
and I'm on the minis right now and by
Christmas all escalate up to a damn full
bar
I'll go mini then I'll go then baby
snicker they went you know and I go full
bar I don't do them big king-size we got
one in here from like a damn museum or
something
or the kind you pull over on the side of
the interstate and in Missouri to take a
picture up with your cousin you sit him
up on the top of it and get a picture of
him but we're not talking no no oh
so one time I remember my dad he was
senior citizen and that's like as much
citizen as you can be really and he's
probably what maybe 75 77 maybe I don't
know maybe I don't know maybe have gone
with about 80 but and he got the bat you
know he got his blood work or something
came back wrong or they gave him a wrong
blood work at the hospital because the
hospital when I was growing up it was
like two guys over there working in a
couple ladies they maybe had four people
over there then one guy was a mechanic
and so he'd come in there and he put it
you know he'd try to cure cancer with a
damn allen wrench in there you know he's
in there fixing a broken arm but um you
know what I uh would a Phillips head
wrench so there was limited ability to
really be you know healed or procured I
mean he if he got healed you were really
lucky so I remember my dad got some bad
the wrong blood work they gave him
somebody else's blood work like I have a
newborn baby or son so he they said he
had the good blood you know sugar was
low and it was right at Halloween and so
dude he got in our Halloween candy he
must a he must aid about
I bet he probably had about a nineteen
Ricci Cup and uh and he he went into a
like a he passed out wedding like a
sugar coma or something and you take him
to the hospital dude in the hospital you
know like I said it's for you know they
got three people over there one of them
to drive through some lady you know they
selling fries out the back of it I mean
it [ __ ] was this was limited time it was
limited ability to really get well I
mean that's why you would either go to
the hospital you were to do prayer
some people just prayer and a my dad
they are mostly it was babies mostly the
hospitals for babies so you take a you
know you take your dad over there
he had like a sugar stroke or something
they put him in a damn incubator you
know they got him in like a damn
nine-foot incubator he's in there you
know doing cigarettes or something
little Daniel come by and sell them a
pack of smokes bro you cuz you know how
Daniel is dirty Dan you don't care if
you get well or not you know he makes
his own choices and he don't like to he
don't care if you get well or not he
does not care but those were the days
man different time you know because you
get a sugar report of an infant next
thing you know you think you can live
how you want you're in college again but
really you're a senior citizen
we don't still have to tell you about
I'll tell you this that if you're
gambling and you should have been on
them in a while and Saints because Drew
Brees man is that come he's so inspiring
you know he's like a UH he's like a
light at the end of the tunnel of
humanity then uh but if you'd like to
bet on games like I do there's only one
real place to do it and the place that I
like to do it is that my bookie my
bookie regardless of whether you been
battling
I'm sorry man I think my lungs is
haunted I think my lungs is haunted man
bye cigarette
bye cigarette so sorry man that's what
I'm saying dude everybody's getting
haunted right now what's in your brain
which is where you you know you got a
dirty ghost in your lung and you got a
[ __ ] little you know you got a ghost
in your wiener or in your coot you know
what I'm saying everybody's got
something haunting them right now
haunting their body haunting their brain
it's that time maybe it's that time
we've all got something haunting us some
people like to gamble
you know don't fly to Vegas to do it in
1900 okay don't get you just fly over
there and you know lie to your wife and
say you go on to the store next thing
you know you go on for four days you
know so what I'm seeing is my bookie do
it the right way whether you've been
betting for years you're ready to play
for the first time my bookie is your
best bet this season make your best bet
if you're the kind of guy who likes to
bet a little and win a lot try a parlay
now a parlay used to be whenever you got
uh whenever you hooked up with a chick
over there on the golf course but this
is different for instance if you like a
couple of the big favorites this week or
in two weeks you want to lay a little
bit of money on them ah LSU Tigers to
beat that Crimson Tide then parlays are
perfect cuz it lets you bet multiple
games together for a bigger payout and
that's how I like to roll all a six
dollars you know I'll bet you know that
that the that the Rottweiler across the
street is gonna be you know is going to
buy one of these you know kids doing
tricks on their bikes but you know if
you want to bet a couple of that on a
couple different streets then you do it
through my bookie that's the parlay
if you're gonna bet this season do the
smart thing go to my bookie dot AG
because no one gives you more ways to
win between football season the playoffs
the start of the NBA NHL it's time to
get off the sidelines and get in on the
action and if you join right now my
bookie they're gonna double your deal
who doubles you deal you ever give
somebody something to give you back
twice as much the Lord may be but they
will double your deal at my bookie use
promo code Theo to activate the offer
that's promo code th EO to double your
cash visit my bookie my bo o ki e AG
today you play you win you get paid get
paid man get that loot get that loot I'm
thinking about going to Louisiana on 3rd
Wednesday to go see the kiddos and a
niece and nephew and you know uh man I
love you know it's a it's a lot this
time of year coming up and I know you
know sometimes we head into the season
and people are dealing with different
stressors and you know maybe you you you
just lost a girlfriend or you just lost
a love winner you know were you're not
sure what to do or you don't know what
your choices are but just just keep
moving forward you know everything will
be okay and I just want to tell you that
and I'm telling myself that too because
I need to hear that from myself
sometimes and I'm not getting all debbie
downer people sometimes say may you know
something you get a little down or and
do it I'm an alcoholic man you know this
is it's a problem that it never doubt
whatever that demon is that dark art
that lives in me that Vincent van Gogh
straw something's haunting it haunts me
and I'm a haunted haunted haunted house
bro and I'm a two-storey bra got a
garage you know I got AB a cement a I
got a damn uh you know a lean-to out
back we got a tree house there's some
[ __ ] haunted territory and
and so it's a constant battle you know
when you have alcoholism and that kind
of thing and stuff it's a constant
battle man it doesn't mean you can't
just beat at once you can't it just it
you it is a fight so you know when some
time I got a little bit of [ __ ] at me
bro when they baked my batch they do a
look you know they do a little a couple
extra [ __ ] little you know half a
scoop a [ __ ] sometimes in me so I got a
battle through that you know through the
through those extra through the extra
you know amount of [ __ ] that's in me
because look dude if I had my choice and
I'm standing there at the checkout I'd
be like I and I hold the [ __ ] you know
I'm saying hold the [ __ ] but that's not
that's not what the deck I was dealt and
so I can only play with these cards that
I have oh man we got some great calls
that came in man I'm so happy to be here
I can't believe this is let me see
December 16th will be three years of
doing this past weekend Wow
three years that's crazy that's like a
three-year-old child that's pretty
bizarre let's take a call or two as
always a hotline nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three
we all got ghosts we all got goes what's
up James from San Jose and San Jose
definitely have been to that place and
it's they got a lot of if you're down
there kind of where the buses aren't
stuck they got a lot of at night a lot
of people will kind of beat each other
out in the street and stuff like that it
has that kind of unique vibe that
outdoors Evod downtown onward [ __ ] I was
just listening to your podcast now
you're talking about
the zoo in the Kulik akan province
oh yeah my buddy got that read down
there on that uh that Sinaloa animal
sanctuary baby
uh yeah what do you know you have any
info I don't know if you know but
we're El Chapo's boys are and they're
going ham right now so I don't know if
that'd be the smartest investment you
just wanted to give you the heads up I
don't know if people want you to news
lately that [ __ ] is going crazy brother
gang gang gang gang man no I didn't know
that thank you for that information
that's one thing I love about this this
back and forth we have here is the
information I receive so if El Chapo's
boys are out there but see that's when I
think people could use an animal the
most you know a couple people getting
murdered or whatever and you get to go
touch a soft animal you know and that's
like it's almost like when you touch the
back of a damn beautiful and when you
touch the back of a beautiful ape or a
beautiful you know a kitten or even one
of those little dogs that's in a
wheelchair or something um there's
nothing more beautiful than that then
rubbing your hand it's almost like
sticking your hand right into Heaven's
ass you know like right into just a
right into heaven when you touch the
back of an animal or the back are you
touch the front of a of a you know a
soft seal or something around ostrich or
yeah or something you know at a petting
zoo you they let you touch a damn
[ __ ] lemur or something or check its
throat for a see if it's nozzles or you
know if I might have a cold or whatever
I mean that that can cure a lot of
people so I'm saying so the thing the
thing about the zoo that gets me is
could it be you know to your friends
just got beheaded you get to go look at
a couple lambs or whatever [ __ ] or
just being together you know cuz it's
not always about sex you know then that
could be something that could be special
but out you know it's crazy because my
boy and even gotten back to me
I mean he's down there getting responded
to like the past four messages so we'll
see man but I got a lot of response
about that people saying dude don't do a
zoo in Mexico
well yeah easy for you to say you don't
have the opportunity to do it so alright
let's we got it we had some calls that
came in about pyramid schemes and I got
schemed out as a child me and my friend
Charlie we lost we lost $1,000 in a
pyramid scheme
and dude I think it was even when I
remember thinking back I think it was
called the pyramid scheme like these
people whoever put it on didn't even
hide and now remember it was like up
here I was like it was a pyramid it said
you know I think it even said don't do
this at the bottom so it was you know it
was it wasn't probably like a premiere
choice but we had some call that came in
about that pyramid hmm and I just had
another snicker boy good God
Who am I what have I done to deserve
this luxury boy when I put a snake on my
face man it's just like mmm my god mmm
it's like my whole tongue just dang went
to church brother mmm god it's like
every one of my teeth just sat down in a
sugary little Sunday School
mmm because my mouth is with the Lord
when I got a snicker in it my god mmm
mommy Benny young in Iraq when a mommy
of being young and erect hmm you know I
used to get so erect as a child I was
like a damn shark Jesus ruining my vibe
dude if you laid me on my back and you
know I look like a damn shark Brock
because I had that wiener topping out up
at the top of my pants and everything
all right some calls came in about
pyramid scheme let's get to one of those
cuz I asked you guys to let me know if
you'd ever done I've been caught up then
the Dark Arts has shapeshifter man that
pyramid you know that said I said the
Bermuda Triangle of your bank account
right there gang CEO what's going on man
if you don't well this is Cody from
Lancaster Pennsylvania Cody from
Lancaster PA and that's Amish country
and the Amish sure I mean they're
beautiful ma'am they're like new they're
like deer like newborn deer endangered
species you need kind of can you can
look at them but you don't want to get
up real close it or steal your chips you
know it's stealing bag of potato chips
out of your hand kind of like those
little monkeys over there and them Oh
Malaysia or even in I think even a lot
of places let's hear more thank you for
calling brother homeward I'm currently
driving from Florida to my hometown I
heard about you talking about a pyramid
scheme
my fiance and I actually got wrapped up
in one of those with Amway amen brother
oh we're doing so uh some babysitting
and the parents of the child actually
just they got us kind of wrapped up and
that gave us a presentation a PowerPoint
slide started unloading products on us
and it was just like you know zero
hundreds and in no time so I gotta tell
ya it's uh it can definitely be
the people there at the top but you know
if you just starting out you have to
start selling your friends and family
and you know that can just be stressful
and you know to be rough man so yeah
just let you know I we got in briefly
got out and you know if anything's about
the money on that so well I'm sorry to
hear that man I appreciate you sharing
Amway I'm guessing that's when they do
the baby powder and yeah I got caught up
in that the Amway people they sell you
anything
hey don't you want this shampoo you know
it's got cinnamon at the bottom you know
but also it has cinnamon at the bottom
real cinnamon dude I don't give a [ __ ]
man I'm trying I'm trying to wash matter
this ain't a damn snickerdoodle you know
so I don't get some time they like Amway
like all you need on they got everything
you know they'll get you involved in all
they get yet I say you everything oh you
need this little long just thing a syrup
you notice thing a syrup it turns into
ice cream at night don't you want a
couple scoops of it [ __ ] no bruh how
about that so but I don't know man I'm
sorry you guys got caught in it but I'll
be careful of that I'll be careful at
that pyramid scheme who else got schemed
out let's take a call right now again yo
big Samuel from Indy and thank you for
calling my friend I was calling to leave
a comment about the period well that's a
yeah a verbal comment gang brother
homework he and my experience with that
yeah people started call me that I had
taught you in ages
you know hey man I got this concrete for
you you know it was like the answer all
your screams that's right okay man I
haven't talked to you in a long time I
appreciate you thinking me I did I felt
like I was loved like people wanted to
give me this this dream that's like okay
I'll go to this meeting it's like a mix
and do it was very cold and very cool a
drinky v and I was instantly freaked out
and they were
handed out drinks it was the place that
supplements me and they're like who'll
try this energy drink packet which it
was just but looking back I think it was
the kool-aid right yeah they want you to
sip the kool-aid that's the thing a
couple years ago I was you know living
my life
and they said hey do you want to come
perform at this function and I think it
was like a couple thousand bucks they
said you want to come perform at this
function might even $1,500 and just come
in the back and we you know we'll meet
you back there and come in and you'd be
going the stage you're gonna perform for
a little while and then Suzanne Somers
gonna do it and Suzanne summer is this
lady I mean she really she looks like
she has a real strong kind of butthole
on her to be honest
and I know I don't I've never said that
about anyone actually but it looks like
her you know her little B hole could
probably I bet it could I bet it could
probably blow a bubble with some gum if
it has gum in it so that's what I'm kind
of saying look like she just has a
really she's real strong she always does
the leg Fitness and um glute fit and you
know glute thickness and glute is just
so you don't say but that's all glue it
is but so I was there I go in the back I
go on a stage I perform it's a little
bizarre it's like all these people
sitting in there you know one dude has
on like a top hat
people are like scream and you know and
fired up and and there's like a clock
that's counting down on the wall like
you know I don't remember where it's at
like 40 minutes or something so then I
get done performing I go back backstage
I haven't even been to the front of the
event so they say look man if you want
to go around front get your little
chocolate cake because they were doing
dinner when I was onstage and they had
just gotten
in a desert portion of the evening and
I'll be honest I love a desert all right
you know I'm sick of people acting like
we just like dinner bitching I like it
all okay I want dessert I want that I
want lime slices I want it all [ __ ]
okay that's who I am I'm sick of sitting
at the menu every time we get the menu
have to look at all the other stuff
first but give me a menu that just has
dessert on it and I'll be fine okay I'll
have nine scoops ice cream that's fine
brah actually I wish they'd served
everything in ice cream salad ice cream
steak ice cream pork chop ice cream dude
I would have it mmm oh so I go around
front I go in then I'm out so now I'm
able to see the stage from the front and
see what everybody else is seeing
there's like this countdown clock of
like when the new product is gonna
launch there's like all of these um it
was cold like yeah it was like a vitamin
thing like power vy or something or some
i don't know what it was dude and they
had these patches you put on your head
and helps you sleep and stuff and when
you put under your neck or whatever and
it keeps ants off your body
they had they had one pie they had like
these other yeah this patches you put
them on your shoulder and you put you
know you'll never think about your
ex-girlfriend or something or you know
they got these patches you it's like um
you put them on the backi legs and you
can drive better just all kind of
[ __ ] but everybody was in there and
they were fired up and the new patches
were about to launch and and i was like
holy [ __ ] mounters performed at a
pyramid scheme I didn't realize I was
like damn I just performed at a pyramid
scheme and I look onstage and Suzanne
Somers up there with that strong ass
freaking back you know that back jaw
she got that real Hardy back Joe and uh
and she was talking about something
magnesium I think or something I don't
know but but yeah we all get caught up
we all get caught up yeah I lost a
thousand as a child and I remember
getting high when I was young too uh
with a with the same kid I lost the
money with you know little Charlie and
he was real real white real white guy
and he wore a lot of Western type of
clothing he had good posture and he he
he was heavily garbed western style he
was you know like a western-style
omelette he was like a western-style
human and one night we got high with a
couple urban gentlemen little clients
and somebody else I don't remember
Christopher I think his name was
beautiful boy long arms I mean this kid
could [ __ ] he could he could rescue
somebody who had fallen down in a hole
easily and we all got real high one time
we're driving in this 84 Ford Escort I
had and they and I got so high I was
like oh you know what to be funny as if
I pull over and say the car won't start
and they'll all get out of the car and
be looking under the hood and it was
midnight man it was nighttime you know
darkness had said so I roll on the side
of the interstate I'm like dang man car
won't start guys said they're all
[ __ ] high as [ __ ] as as so was I also
so everybody was and they get out the
car and uh and they were looking under
the hood for so long man indeed I was
laughing so [ __ ] hard I never laughed
so hard in my life man I never laughed
so hard in my life
they're like what is there like a floor
it you know because if you don't know
[ __ ] about
you know when cars are broken here's
what you do you go you open the hood
your buddies in there you say hey brah
floor it and he'll floored it makes a
loud sound and then you say I don't know
what the problem is brother so yeah man
they had a and I just kept telling them
that it wouldn't start I just kept
telling them that it would not start I
don't know why I did it but God still
just good times you gotta have fun with
people you gotta have fun with yourself
let's take another call that came in
about the scheme yeah CJ from Houma
Louisiana big CJ down there in Houma and
the east is yeah people will be like oh
I got a lot of homosexuals out there and
that means just people from Houma and
that's not what you you know it doesn't
mean you prefer someone of the same sex
so good to hear from your brother
homeward 95 baby gang bro I actually got
into a pyramid scheme because of my mom
I was actually my mom's first customer
and dang now that's dark arts brah hmm
man you really that's why let's hear
more yeah I had to give her $600 which
was all the money I had cuz I was only
like 18 at I'm 17 18
oh man that's when they got me to man
when I was young and we found out one of
my buddies his parents hehe got duped
and his parents got duped let's hear
more and then I got my cousin's involved
in it dude it ruin and it ruins families
showed them that got their money yeah
cuz cousins they'll do all kind of [ __ ]
bro cousins you know they especially
second or third cousin if you can't even
make first chair when it comes to begin
at cousin bruh
no yeah I'll get you into a pyramid
scheme because we don't have that for
you know you second third cousin do
you might as well be almost an enemy
homeward so we were all kind of involved
in it but they would make us go to these
trips also like different states and
stuff and duties like conventions I went
to this one convention in Vegas and I
like basically I just like the weapons
on the floor in someone's hotel room and
I was pretty awkward it's probably the
worst experience being in Las Vegas of
1718 but yeah pretty much the falling
out was just like obviously we didn't
make any money yeah I lost a lot of
friendships trying to get people in the
business a lot of high school
friendships and some family members and
my mom never gave me that $600 back so I
gained game
damn man is you know it's hard when you
mix money and family when you mix stuff
like that sorry I just had another I had
another one mmm and this one's starting
to be I'm having a little bit too many
um it's hard when you mix family and the
money and everybody's people
fist-fighting
me and my friend we didn't talk for a
long time because of the pyramid scheme
cuz he lost the money and I lost the
money and we had a square and we kept
calling somebody else and then somebody
died and they didn't man yeah I don't
know who wins I wonder if there's just
somebody who's just going town to town
just you know like just Jerry pyramid
and he's winning them all but I'm sorry
about that the you went to Vegas hmm I
mean you really went through it brother
and it haunts you man that's the thing
it haunts you I still get a little mad
about that but I'm glad I only lost that
and that that little bit in the
beginning
I'm glad you only lost that 600 then
gonna get me again that's it homeward
hey wassup the others landed I'm from
Dallas Texas make a landing down here in
Dallas and I like Dallas man uh I
definitely have been down there and
you know gotten involved in some you
know I've had honestly man I felt some
pretty hard titties down there and
Dallas a long time ago back when the
hard titties was more popular more
currently living in LA though I just
wanted to call in about pyramid schemes
you know they were talking about that
shady triangle I personally haven't been
in one but my mom was that real pyramid
scheme queen hmm oh yeah
one of those mid biddies Brown gang she
she loved it
she finally got out of it thank God so
she's teetering and I could see her
ordering things again she used to order
a lot of packages to our door of
different types of accoutrements that
you would get in a pyramid scheme she
would try to rank up I remember one time
she said she was about five sales away
from getting a free BMW hmm we still
drive a Chevy she did probably about
five pyramid schemes when I was a child
damn you mom's like basically the
Ayatollah or whatever man she's like the
Egyptian queen really Euphrates or
something you know what I'm saying but
she's that's crazy yang you're always
five cars away you're always five sales
away from winning it you know the little
you know homemade starburst maker or
whatever or you know something you know
when them little ice-cream makers or
whatever you can have at the house snow
cone maker then piece of [ __ ] dude armor
buying a snow cone maker one time this
[ __ ] was about nine dollars and it was
basically just like a little hatchet
kind of like a little kind of very not
even a hard hatchet like a little safe
axe and like a little cup in there and
you had to like bring known ice and beat
that [ __ ] up and Jesus Christ man I wish
I just had never gotten bought in that
and I think took a couple years off my
life the stress of trying to just make a
damn cold treat for myself you know when
I was young but still kind of haunted by
that let's take another call here man
the hotline is always ninety five six
sixty four nine five zero three
again we got that out that Lafayette
show I also want to thank we got some
beautiful pumpkins here in studio today
and they're done by mr. Brian Johnson
and I'll put them on the Instagram and
tag him and he does some really amazing
art and Brian Johnson studios is his uh
his IG handle sorry Brian
B Rin Johnson studio and he did some
real cool with the cartoon Rat King you
know he really got into it and and in it
and it's that time this past weekend is
brought to you by Skillshare Skillshare
is an online learning community for
create tours with more than 25,000
classes and design business and more
you'll discover so many ways to stay
curious and creative let me say I think
creativity is one of the things that
dies fast it really does you know we get
locked in this cauldron of just
commonality and to be creative and to
say you know to keep the decay the
caverns of your mind open it's tough
it's a fight it's a battle and you got
to battle for that you got to battle for
that square footage of freedom and uh
and skill share will help you you can
take classes in social media marketing
mobile photography even illustration
skills share is there to keep you
learning you want to try graphic design
try it they have a class graphic design
basics core principles for visual design
join a millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with the
special offer just from our listeners
you get two months of Skillshare for
free that's right Skillshare is offering
tpw listeners two months of unlimited
access to over 25,000 classes for free
to sign up go to Skillshare comm slash
Theo von again go to Skillshare comm
slash Theo von to start your two months
now
um yeah you're always five sails away
from a BMW man you know yet us you know
while we just on the verge we're just on
the verge dude you don't right after
Halloween it's gonna be Thanksgiving I
mean it's gonna be like fast and then
it's gonna be Christmas and it's gonna
be New Year's it's gonna be fast dude
that's like what whenever you hear a kid
say like oh yeah I'm seven and a half
it's like bro nobody gives a [ __ ] about
the half dude nobody's milling around
being like all is he gonna get there you
know nobody's looking at you when aiming
like oh he's seven years and 56% okay so
tight you you know you know tone it down
a little bucko oh yeah I'm 50 I'm 50 and
a half you know what I'm saying that's
the weirdest dude some guy who's like 50
and a half years old and he tells you
that that dude that guy's from somewhere
else bro
maybe Dutch or something you know the
Dutch a real aerodynamic as well I don't
know if we've if I brought that up or
not but if you want to see somebody go
downhill quickly and and really be good
at it that's the Dutch they're so
aerodynamic you can't beat it no one can
let's say a patreon our question came in
we're gonna do this we can all went to
autistic comedy actually I had four sets
I had a bunch of sets this week working
on some new material and it felt real
good to get back on stage I have been
honest you know haven't been inspired
really that recently I don't know what's
going on I just you know you know me
something I got these ghosts in my brain
and but man it felt good this weekend
got out there dude
Bobby Lee blessum showed me pictures he
has pictures of his fault when his
father was deceased
he has pictures in there with him and
his father and his family and the dad's
laying there you know gone I mean the
dad is going his spirits going on but
they're milling around with the UH with
the with the dad bod I guess you call it
dad bought yeah they're milling around
with the dad bod so that was and he
showed us the pictures he showed us the
pictures I think it's like a traditional
Korean thing where you know you you know
show pictures of your you know kind of
like honor your parents or something
because they used to do hieroglyphs that
would you know if your parents died they
would draw it on the wall you know they
get a little sword or something draw it
on the wall but now that you know you
can't people draw on their walls as much
because it's not caves and stuff people
you know everybody's wants to resell
their house so and he showed us the
images dude it was very very interesting
it's kind of beautiful though kind of
beautiful here's a question that came in
from Alex Gebhardt did hard to Theo I've
declared myself the world's worst
procrastinator I'm currently taking a
coding course and I'm behind so many
assignments because I just don't want to
do them do you have our problems
procrastinating and what do you do to
pull yourself out of it yeah man I do
and I have problems I'm upset at
procrastinating years ago I look except
for things I mean most of my 20s was
procrastinating and honestly man just
chasing leg chasing woman you know
chasing nah you know chasing Teddy boy
so so yeah I got that man what do I do
to pull myself out of it well some of it
I noticed is my nature you know I'm kind
of that like you know I'm that last
chance Lance I do well at the end you
know I do well at the end I do well when
the pressure is on but a you know when I
do really well when when I start early
that's when I really really do I find
excel at stuff so I think just
motivation you know life is a program of
action I talked to a friend this week I
was you know having tough time with some
stuff the past couple weeks and so you
know and I'm always thinking about
things I'm always thinking about how I
feel I'm feeling about how I think and
he said hey man life's a program it's a
it's a it's a program of action we could
think of a feel and that's okay those
things are real and we need to do that
we need to process what's going on with
us and and share with other people so we
don't have like these things trapped in
us but at a certain point it's a it's a
program of action people that win or
people that act people that achieve
their goals or their dreams or get what
they want it's people that take action
that's it and the other stuff is good
but it's really it's a program of action
and now and it's hard for me to stomach
that sometimes but it's the truth and
yeah if you're so far behind man I think
set aside a day go to the library make
it something fun go have kind of a new
experience I'm gonna get me a coffee I'm
gonna go to the library I'm gonna do my
work you know get done what I need to do
I'm gonna get a classmate to hold me
accountable say you you want to work on
this together can we do that because
I'll tell you this do it if you
procrastinate now that kind of stuff
doesn't go away very easily you know you
really have to make some efforts for
change if you want to now if you're just
gonna procrastinate on don't be too hard
on yourself that's what I do you know
I'm gonna beat myself up instead of
enjoying my procrastination get a pizza
bro you know I'm saying get a [ __ ]
ice cream get some pizza ice cream and
douse yourself out there and live it
right bro okay
this is a patreon question came in
Amanda Grayson after working in
Corrections for the last two years I've
seen what the dark arts can do to people
can you offer some suggestions on how to
stay kind and not be cynical in a
negative and manipulative environment
wow I can only imagine what that's like
you know you're in Corrections you go in
there every day and your work and really
with the with the outcasts and the the
dregs and the people that are evil and
afflicted and also people that are
mentally not well people that have been
neglected I mean you're working in the
bottom you're working at a very unique
layer of humanity and also a little in a
layer where you guys are probably
perceived as the enemy even though
you're just somebody is going in and
clocking in a work you didn't make the
choices for this person you know you
didn't set the circumstances you weren't
the parents of them that set the you
know set the framework of their life but
you're really you're having to live you
know with uh with what's you know you
having to be there work frontline with
them mm-hmm
you know I have trouble with it too I
have trouble being cynical and being
judgemental and I think you know praying
for your enemy can really help praying
for your enemy you know just try to do
do what's right and if they see it you
know if people see it some of them will
see it someone will remember you know
it's so funny to me the people that
influenced me in my life ever think that
if you went back and looked at my life
and you let somebody else I hate pick
out the people that influenced this
fella I don't know you might not get him
right because sometimes it was just
certain moments when I was willing to
hear somebody or when I was you know
somebody could tell me something a
million times and I couldn't hear it but
then one day you know uh you know a
basketball coach or a camp counselor or
somebody just had you know who had me in
assert you know just in a certain
or a certain place where I was feeling I
was willing to hear what was going on or
willing to hear some advice or
suggestion and and I would you know it's
just kind of interesting so I think just
do you best be an example but also at
some point saying you you're down there
dealing with people that some of them is
just they they're just an extension of
the devil you got there you know you
really the prison is basically just like
a it's like the Hardys of Hades you know
you got a lot of real devil dwellers out
there so just you know do your best and
keep the light alive in you because I
bet it can be easy to get pulled down
man it's like working right out there on
this like it's like it almost if you
took Hades it was a piece of water and
you put a just a boat dock out into it
and that's the correctional but I bet
there's one or two people you can
inspire so look for them maybe and I
think just maybe see what's similar
between you and those people listen for
the similarities between because there's
some things where you guys are both just
human and you'll have very similar and
maybe those would be places where you
can make little bridges with people um
what's going on and also I don't know
you know I'm just I don't have any
experience down there but I do know that
the dark arts man it's uh you know the
coffins are open right now and you can
hear you can hear it all happening all
right let's hit this um this call that
came in right here nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three as well
there's a show at The Wiltern in Los
Angeles December 10th and that's a
that's a show that would be good to get
a ticket - I think it's almost nearing
sellout and what else all went met with
uh you know you met with a cartoonist
company who's made some pretty big
cartoons about possibly doing something
with the animations that we've been
doing
so that could be pretty cool you never
know but that could be pretty cool yeah
and what else I'm just you know I'm
starting to feel a little bit less
stressed than I was earlier in this year
man I really I was not I was not doing
really well
it was tough I was having a tough time
all right let's keep it trapped bruh um
here we go
hey uh this is hunter from Shelby North
Carolina
what's up hunter over there in that
cackalacky boy that North Carolina gang
bro give me what you got for a pork chop
right outside of Charlotte so I got a
DWI last thing about a week ago I'm 25
and uh but it's my second DWI I got my
first one when I was 17 and I blew a
point for you well now I've blown a
point oh nine for this one oh wow so you
probably you like the damn Rain Man or
breathalyzers about you hitting them
numbers though you know I'm saying you
might want to play the scratchers or
whatever due to um pick three Albert as
well but it falls within a seven-year
period to where you can't have two duis
in North Carolina within seven years or
you get mandatory jail time and so in ER
I got I got my old lady and my dog I was
just bought a house I had to drop out of
school I guess someone try to find a job
or something somewhere so I can look
good to the judge I guess but I guess
I'm really just stressing this this
going to jail thing I just wanted to get
some love some advice from in and you
know I guess just here you make
something funny about it something made
me laugh but uh gang bruh well dude it's
hard I mean if you really from a place
called Chevy North Carolina I mean look
that up isn't really Chevy North
Carolina I was gonna say do this hard
not to get a DUI when your town isn't
even for a damn truck um do you I can't
believe you blew that point on Island
two times you should tell the judge that
like look I'm the breathalyzer whisperer
okay every time I puff into that [ __ ] I
hit the numbers yeah I'm saying you
might want to go out just telling me you
know you might want to start being a
bookie or something my breath bookie and
uh I mean it sucks dude ah you know what
sucks kind of is if you you know if you
guys were you know a lot of wealthy
people get out of this kind of [ __ ] cuz
they get the right attorneys and blah
blah blah you know and and that's where
people you know from regular places like
us they don't we don't have the same
opportunity sometimes but those people
who get out of things like this that
they're just kicking the can down the
road they don't learn their lesson so
maybe you just had some bad luck you
know if you got to in seven years that's
not insane but it's a I don't want to
say that's a pattern but it ain't
[ __ ] cool you know it ain't good it
ain't great and I know you know that man
I'm not trying to preach at you but then
my leash if you go do a little bit of
time but I think your wife will think
that's sexy as hell you know having to
drop out of school if you do go in man I
would just use it as time to to prepare
for something or to you know study or to
just be to come out and be you know
really streamline headed into what you
want to head into it may be a good time
for you to give you some time to think
about stuff I mean I'm hoping it's just
a couple of months or you know but am
and also you can't be in people's in
there for doing fires an arson you know
murder
you know outdoor murder and Dormer
all kind of stuff uh and you in there
just for you know you had a couple of
bush lights and [ __ ] decided to floor
it on the way home I think you got to
come up with a better you got to come up
with a good crime that you did trying to
cover a real good crime mmm what's a
good crime doing you know what you could
always tell me you tickled the cop after
they pulled over I think there's
something kind of wild about that
because anybody could shoot somebody or
do this or that but somebody tickle a
damn cop bra people say what you in for
like I just been tickling the police son
like damn I'm gonna give that guy mom my
uh my bread roll at UH at dinner because
that dude is that kind of guy who's
[ __ ] not afraid if I can put both of
his all ten of his fingers into a cop's
ribs and wiggle him around
hmmm boy that's something serious days
so yeah I would tell people even for
tickling the police bro because there's
something kind of [ __ ] artsy about
that but stay safe and give your wife a
big hug man and uh you're lucky to have
somebody to support you if you do have
to struggle with that and I'm sorry that
people like where we're from don't have
the same opportunity to get out of some
of the [ __ ] but the [ __ ] stays
it just I adds up so no matter what's
going on
however this shakes out I think if you
can get to the core whatever the issue
is would you have a drinking problem you
have a driving problem I'm saying one of
them you I think you have an issue at
one of them so maybe next time if you
take all you maybe have your buddy take
all your tires off your truck or
something if you're gonna go drinking
you know make a rule or something you
know at least two tires so be well
brother homework all right let's take
this call right here here we go one more
call maybe maybe I don't know
it's Halloween man I've been trying to
just I'm not trying to do anything man
I'm just trying to keep it going
I'm trying to keep it going man that's
all we got to do you know I'm so tired
of my brain making plans with me my
brains always like every time I do
something it's like okay now we're doing
this okay now we're doing this you know
my brain it just it just always finds
the problem it's like my brain is like a
vacuum and it only it's like a room but
one of them thing that's vacuums like
you're going you know rumbas somebody
call it you know rumors of those things
you turn it on it's supposed to clean
your house while you're while you're
away
but there's videos a lot couple rumors
outside you know smoke and you know
somebody caught two-room was [ __ ]
outside of their garage so everybody
want to talk about how artificial
intelligence is gonna be the future and
everything like that you know I mean you
got meanwhile you got a you know a
Roomba and one of these nest thermostats
and they meet and they meet up outside
of the garage and you know cooking up a
gram or something or heating up a couple
of uh you know batches it at greenie
it's just I mean artificial intelligence
is only as good as the dope it's going
to get into so next time you you know
you you and you know you look in the
washroom you find some drugs and they're
something that might not be your
husband's your husband's stash how do
you know that you know some of these
machines ain't doing the [ __ ] you know
next time they pull you over and they
search your car and they finally you
know a couple little sacks of quaaludes
or uh you know in a little um mason jar
of uh KY jellies or something preserves
preferably because you don't hang out
like a little bit of chunk in it but uh
but just say hey man you know I don't
know what this car does at night I Drive
this [ __ ] during the day okay I don't
know what this thing it might be you
know rolling over there to the Chevrolet
dealership
and in free Basin I don't know what you
know I'm saying I don't know but I'm
just saying at a certain point
artificial intelligence is gonna be so
smart easily it could get easily it
could do drugs so that's that's what I'm
saying I read an article the other day
they found a toaster that had a couple
um doing dabs so what is that you
telling me it just what was this guy
talking about sorry did anybody even
call I don't even know what's happening
um let me take a call right now here we
go homework oh this is a written written
callin from Tacoma Washington I just got
finished listening to the last podcast
I think thanks for listening man thanks
for your patience you know when it's
funny cuz sometime I come in I don't
know what this podcast gonna be like I
don't know what's gonna happen you know
I don't know how I'm feeling I don't
know how you're feeling but we keep
showing up man I'm grateful for that
you know to the person that called
earlier it's like you just keep doing it
you got to just keep going if you
procrastinate and then no matter it's
it's a program of action you know
existence is a program of action it's
like we can feel and do all these things
and talk about how we feel and it's
important and it's real but at a certain
point you know we have to take action we
have to onward let's go brother the end
you're talking about the middle ground
that we sort of live in my question is
to you or anyone listening if this makes
it in how do you change your desires to
be sort of positive or good like I want
to have both hands on the board and move
forward but part of me feels like I like
the dark arts if I'm going to be honest
so anyway let me know what you think
gang bruh you know I feel I feel you
right there
you know I feel you right there it's
like I want to be I mean I talked about
this before I want to be part of the
solution I want to be I want to live in
the good space I want to you know I want
that freedom that I have that's that
people have and it's tougher sometimes
for some people than it is for others
and unfortunately for me that's you know
that's some of my battle and that's okay
some people at different battles some
people have you know wasps in their
house some people you know have trouble
battling and you know the the dim
elements the dark hearts man and and
that's me I want to do something bad a
lot of times you know I'm gonna be dirty
I want to be you know a naughty naughty
naughty naughty naughty type of guy but
at the same time there's a bigger thing
as a light in me that wants to do that
once that wants to be and that wants to
be part of the solution because once you
especially if you can be part of this if
you're if you can then you can help
other people you can be an example you
know and I get people sent messages a
lot of times like hey thank you you know
for talking about sobriety and talking
about the things you struggle with and
and and you're welcome man you're
welcome you know it makes me feel I
don't know yeah I want to be okay two
minutes hard and some of that I think
for some of us that's our battle that's
our journey and there has to be a
journey in life I think there needs to
be I think that's what this this world
is it is a it is a fight it is a battle
hard sometimes you know it's a hard
thing to admit man I was thinking
earlier it's hard to admit that I love
God man you know and not even knowing
sometimes who God is or what it is or
but that I love him you know it's hard
to admit that because there's this other
these other strings man there's these I
want to pull yeah it's just your own
will and stuff you want to do and and
I'm not saying that like you know some
people believe in religion some people
don't and that's that's fine I don't
knock anyone that doesn't but but I just
know the I struggle I struggle with it
you know I feel sometimes like I'm
afraid or I think some that holds me
back as I'm afraid to go all the way in
because I feel like I won't be able to
have fun I won't be able to and you know
but I know that's not the truth though
man but I think being honest with
ourselves like you're doing is it's a
good part of the journey because then at
least whatever powers are out there for
good can meet us where we are
you know if I'm always standing around
saying oh this is why I am and I'm doing
great and this and that and and I'm not
realistic then how is the other piece of
the puzzle that I need can ever match up
with me if I keep shape-shifting you
know if I keep shape-shifting my shape
to fit you know whatever conversation
I'm in or you know I struggle and I
don't know man
but I like your your thought about being
honest about there's something special
about that because then whatever the
other piece is and you know whatever the
other interactions I need in the world
they're gonna help me feel more whole
those are gonna be able to meet my ass
boy because otherwise if I keep saying
oh well this is really one this is where
I'm at then all these things
miss them because because that's not
really the shape I'm I'm in and I'm in
pretty good shape for the shape that I'm
in making it that's a bishop gun song
thanks for calling man thanks your
honesty uh what else what else don't
want to talk about I don't know you know
I don't know man I you know I had so
much fun this weekend us at the comedy
club watching Chris D'Elia you know such
a stepdad you know people want to say
he's this father figure and he's this in
that babies what who's hanging out with
babies dude pede pede de Leo files
that's who do we have an struggling semi
adult adolescent audience right that's
where we're at but baby doesn't go crawl
off a cliff brah which is sacrificial
lambs and that ain't us man we just I
don't know what we are man we just a
bunch of freaking rats brah but I know a
lot of you guys are gonna be out there
this weekend taking your children out or
taking your friends out or doing
something fun and and I hope you will
just enjoy the experience you know be
brave dress in a costume do something
kind of fun you know if you're taking
your old lady out you know don't have a
frown on your face you know try and have
a new experience you know I've had women
in my life and I've missed out on the
opportunity to uh to to lift them up you
know I was thinking the other day about
myself one thing I noticed recently was
I've always struggled with uh I've never
really honored the women in my life
you know I've never really honored them
I've always for some reason been like
ashamed or didn't want to be attached
[Music]
you know I've always had a really a
strong block when it came to honoring
the women in my life that a bit that
were important to me and that have been
important to me I'm trying to think
about it for a second huh I try to feel
about it I feel like I mean I think I
have a lot of regret when it comes to
that I've just never you know I think a
lot of times when I was young I was
always ashamed of my mother you know I
was ashamed that you know that she
wasn't like this idea I guess of a
mother I think I just wish I'd have been
stronger to like you know just lift her
up just say you know I'm proud of my
mother you know and I think that's a
dad's jobs and diamonds to teach the son
to do that and my mom didn't when I
weren't very close but but yeah I don't
know if just I was realizing that the
other day I've always struggled with
honoring the women in my life it's not
because I don't care about him it's just
I don't know I think I was just I don't
know maybe I was just so self-sufficient
at an early age you know you know and I
wanted more from a relationship but my
mom but I didn't have it or something I
don't know or maybe I was just selfish
[Music]
I don't know I'm trying to feel it and I
can't really land on anything but I've
always whenever it's coming to
girlfriend they're like you know saying
oh this is my girlfriend or this is a
girl that I'm seeing it's always been
really tough for me you know always had
my mom like dropped me off kind of like
you know not by the party wherever we
were going I mean half the time I to
walk to the thing or whatever thing I
was going to as well so maybe I was just
angry sometimes but you know I've always
struggled with having that just not
honoring you know the women in my life
just saying hey this is my girlfriend or
this is my wife or this is this girl
that I'm dating and I'm proud to be with
them um I think for me some of it is
just commitment I don't want any I don't
want you know I like to just do it
myself I don't I don't know I just want
to be must I just want to be just me and
it just gets really tough when uh you
know I don't know just something that
honestly for me that has been kind of
haunting me recently it
haunts me because then people it's tough
for you anyway I was just saying if you
have a you know if someone you're
spending time with you know make sure
they know that you're excited to spend
time with them you know to have a new
moment with them and say look you know I
know we you know our lives sometimes get
kind of the same and we do this and we
do that make up a nice card or something
you know just tell them how much you
care but like in a in a way where they
are gonna notice it because we need that
you know we all need it and and yeah
just sometimes when I have you know I
procrastinate even when it comes to
matters of the heart and of the you know
[Music]
yeah people want to know how much
everybody wants to be cared for
I think yet for me sometimes I was just
so worried about being cared for that I
forgot to X we get to be the other half
of the care in certain environments um
anyway I don't mean to bring this down
at all and it's not down you know that's
what happens when the cauldron is
brewing and that's what happens when the
coffin is open and that's what happens
when the cats have nine lives in no
lives and the mummies got something in
their tummy that's what happens the dark
arts are bound and the things that haunt
us are there they're right here they're
fresh right now they've been in the
crisper drawer of the great beyond of
the upside down and that door has just
been you woven the fridge and that door
is open and suddenly there's nothing in
it because the things that haunt us and
the things that scare us and the things
that you know that dog-whistle that only
we can hear because it's some memory
from our own past
those things are alive right now this is
that time it's that time when it's all
open and it's all upside down you guys
take care of yourselves uh be good to
yourself you deserve it
you know be good to yourself you deserve
it in and if you made a mistake there'll
be so many opportunities to write those
you know there will be opportunities to
right our wrongs but just hold the line
right now it's a tough time you know the
skeletons are are here you'll find an
extra femur you'll wake up in the
morning and find an extra [ __ ] femur
in your hand
whose is this I don't know but it's that
time of year happy Halloween
[Music]
oh it's that one where someone's getting
beaten Jesus Oh Oh Oh God it sound like
two gay guys kind of slapping each other
doesn't it Jesus where the hotties at
man let me see if I can find something
minute some chicks in the back mr.
Dexter hit her right there
[Music]
I like it though
I want to thank Brian Johnson's studio
for these beautiful carvings man you
outdid yourself and you always do time
and time again I want to thank Nick
Davis for making this happen I'm making
this beautiful set for us today I want
to thank you guys for lifting me up and
being a part of my life and a man I'm
excited we're gonna put some new dates
on the books even gonna slowly kind of
wade back into some new stuff got some
new material brewing trying to convince
akima eat a comedian to uh to do a
unique tour with me this summer and go
out together so hopefully we'll see what
he says
[Music]
but thank you guys you know I love you
you know I love you and uh and we got
this there's a beautiful Tommy or a
beautiful time of year you know for us
there's a lot we can do so if you're
struggling with something just hold the
line we got this
I'm have one more that's it just cuz oh
man my heart start nothing can beat fast
[Music]
hmm my god footage annum dude what is
inside to sit inside of Snickers dude
cigarettes they are good my gang